agence pôle emploi j'écoute ah non je
suis désolé ce n'est pas moi la cause
connaissent que vous avez l'instant
toute bonne nouvelle vous n'êtes plus
demandeurs d'emploi quelqu'un qui
démarre aujourd'hui dans la vie active
marie doit être concerné si on commence
tous à se couvrir d'injures ya peut être
motivé oui il n'aimait pas les noirs
contraire j'adore tout ce que fruits
seul que je vous chie sur la tête
monsieur parce que ça aussi je peux le
faire et non au recul à bhl et non vous
êtes l'agent selon la plus performante
aux portelois de boisement et comme dans
un rescrit dans votre agence on va la
fermer
il n'y a plus de travail je ne peux pas
bah voilà là c'est bobby c'est beau
gachi bogeys et trois bogeys et un
double bogey
oui c'est ce que je dis boby c'est quoi
votre petit nid moi j'adore ce prénom
martin à la montagne martine à la plage
est aussi beau le beau le blog bug à
vous l'avez donc et c'est pourquoi on va
se retrouver son travail parce qu'il n'y
a plus assez de chômeurs vient de
pointer l agence on a trop bien
travaillé si on arrête de trop bien
travaillé et re aura plein de chômeurs
ils pourront pas refermer la chance on
va fabriquer du chômage mais
complètement merdique ton plan là
on va saboter le recrutement de la stax
de l'intérieur mais vous feriez un très
très bon directeur commercial je connais
toutes les ficelles du métier vous dire
qu'avec des cas comme ça dans l' usine
au couple va parler - manutentionnaires
je n'ai pas problème
c'est tout si c'est tout va tension bien
sûr vous serez payé comme une femme
moins qu'un homme
le plaisante jean-pierre